-Hey, Colin.
How are you, buddy?
-Hey, good.
How are you, Seth?
-[ Laughing ] Good.
So, you are in Montauk
right now.
This is the house
that you filmed your three
"Weekend Update" --
your quarantine editions
of "Weekend Update," correct?
-That's correct, yes.
-Obviously, we both have friends
who are very kind
with their gifts.
You sent me a photo of what
your co-anchor, Michael Che,
sent you for your birthday.
-[ Laughing ] Yeah.
It was really a photo
I could only send
to fellow comedy writers.
[ Laughs ]
Michael Che
sent me a box on my birthday.
And the card
that came with the box said,
"Dress for the job you want."
And then, I open the box,
and it was a police uniform,
a police officer's uniform
with a Republican National
Convention badge on it.
And I opened it,
and I was like, "I don't --"
I laughed so hard
for like two minutes straight
and then had no idea
what to do with it.
And my friends were like,
"You should take one --
Might as well just take
one picture in it."
I was like,
"That is the worst advice."
Like, "Oh, yeah,
what could go wrong
with one picture of you in it?"
[ Both laugh ]
-What I love the most about it
is a good amount
of thought and care
had to go into it.
-Oh, my God.
-He really went the extra mile.
-In the middle of a quarantine,
to track down
an official police uniform
and get it in the mail
to be delivered
by someone's birthday
when other people can't get,
like, toilet paper.
[ Laughs ]
-Colin, Che is
a huge friend to you.
He is a great supporter of you.
You are the person
who found him for "SNL,"
so you guys are really close.
And yet he actively tries
to cancel you on social media.
This is a photo that he posted
on Instagram we have.
So, this is -- you guys
are hanging out together,
having a nice time.
-Yes.
He came to visit me.
It was very nice, and we got
to catch up and hang out.
We were driving around.
And he, of course, noticed
that the local drugstore
is named "Whites."
[ Both laugh ]
And so he had me loop around
in front of it again
and then take a photo
of the two of us.
I was smiling in the photo.
He is grimacing.
[ Both laugh ]
And then, he wrote
that he made --
that I made him wait in the car
so that I could go into the
drugstore to buy TIKI torches.
So I could go into Whites
And then, the first comment
on the video is someone saying,
"I don't understand.
Are you guys friends or not?
Why would he do this?"
And Che immediately responds,
"We are not friends.
I think that's obvious."
[ Both laugh ]
And then,
everything he's been --
every post,
even if it's unrelated to me,
he's just been putting
#CancelJost.
[ Laughing ]
-And you are currently on
a press tour for your new book.
-Yeah.
-And this is a time
that I assume you have
a publicist working with you
to help you manage the press.
What does your publicist
feel about
how your friend
is lending a helping hand?
-I would probably say
trepidation,
deep anxiety, confusion.
[ Laughing ]
-As a friend to you,
I was very happy --
And again, I think this is
anyone's goal in life
is that your friends
will write a memoir
and you will end up in it.
And there are multiple stories
about a trip that my brother,
Andy Samberg, and you took
to Scandinavia back in '07.
And I'm very glad that you --
I think a lot of people,
if this happened to them,
they would maybe leave it out
of their memoir,
but you are very honest
in this book,
and you do admit to the fact
that you fell asleep
in a graveyard
in Helsinki, Finland.
-That's correct.
I come forward.
I come clean on that.
-[ Laughs ]
-My favorite detail about it is,
you know how bad I am
both with managing time
and understanding
the concept of time.
And I remember
I fell asleep in what --
I took a nap on the way home,
walking home
through Helsinki, Finland,
alone at 3:00 in the morning.
I got tired, and I was like,
"I better take a power nap
halfway through this city
I've never been in at night."
And I went into
what I thought was a park.
-Sure.
-And went into --
-So, of course, a great place
for a nap at 3:00 a.m.
Went into a park, fell asleep,
and then woke up
what I thought was hours later,
and saw that
I was surrounded by tombstones,
and that the park
was actually not a park
and more of an active cemetery.
-Yeah.
-And then, I came --
when I finally came back
and found you at the hotel
and woke you up,
I was like, "Oh, my God, Seth,
I've been asleep
in a graveyard for hours.
I must've been in there,
if not hours, maybe days even."
And you were like,
"Colin, it's been 45 minutes.
We saw you 45 minutes ago
at a bar.
There's no way it was hours."
And that is my sense of time.
And then your brother,
very lovingly,
we were sharing a room.
He very lovingly saw
I was in a bad way,
took all the pillows
from his bed,
sheets from his own bed,
made me a beautiful
makeshift bed
next to his own bed for me
to sleep on and rest.
And I, after he put
all that work in,
I fell asleep
directly next to him.
-[ Laughing ]
-Not touching any of the blanket
or pillows
that he had set up lovingly
and fell asleep on a hard
Helsinki wood floor
for the night.
-And I know people are thinking,
"Oh, you guys
are a little old for this."
But this was a long time ago.
And when this happened,
I was in my mid 30s.
[ Both laugh ]